atop Earth's highest mountain above sea
level hardly seems like an easy place to
live
Mount Everest tall Peaks freezing
temperatures fierce winds and
ever-present snow make it hard to
support life and while it's true that
very few plants or animals can survive
there the most famous resident certainly
seems at home
the Yeti the huge hairy monster has been
spotted walking across Asian mountains
from China to the Himalayas some say it
looks like an 8 others a bear and others
even insist it's an unidentified
humanoid species the first reports of a
wild man in the Himalayas appeared in
the Western world during the 19th
century
but didn't really get much attention but
in the 20th century a few expeditions
some reported tracks and one very famous
photograph began a crazed hunt for the
Yeti
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
it's generally believed Yeti is a
mispronunciation of the word yet tip
from Tibetan Sherpa dialect meaning
either cliff dwelling bear or animal of
rocky places regardless when you hear
Yeti you probably picture the huge
creature with fluffy white fur that pops
up in movies all the time the one
commonly called the abominable snowman
but there's no real folklore that
supports that version before the 20th
century written accounts of the Tibetan
legend of the Yeti date back to the 12th
century
also called a wild man many accounts
describe the creature as an ape-like
being over six feet tall walking on its
back legs with reddish-brown fur
covering its muscular body explanations
range for real animal displaced in
search of food to a purely fictional
folklore creature Tibetan tradition
recognizes a variety of Yeti one such
walk on two legs in another larger Yeti
that preys on livestock and walks on
four
yetee are believed to live in the alpine
forest below the snowline although they
will brave higher altitude for food and
shelter they don't eat or hunt humans
although they may steal food from them
preferring the mosses frogs and pikas
that live on the mountain in many
stories the Yeti is nocturnal and emits
a high-pitched screech or whistle in
Tibetan tradition it is more common to
hear Yeti than to see one the two-legged
meta appears in Buddhist temple
decorations and religious painted
Scrolls according to a religious and
historical Tibetan text from the 12th
century these wild people and humans
come from shared ancestors although the
meta is neither fully human nor fully
animal this is why much of the art in
Tibetan temples shows the Yeti realm of
rebirth between humans and animals and
Tibetan Buddhist stories feature yetis
as both kind and malevolent characters
one popular tale from the Himalayas
tells of an injured yogi helping a wild
man with an infected foot from a
splinter the yogi kindly removes the
splinter and cleans the wound The
Grateful Yeti thanks the yogi by
bringing him a tiger which the man's
skins and offers to a monastery legends
are often born when we blur the lines
between fiction and real-life events in
the 17th century a buddhist religious
leader walked from india to nepal to
reside in a cave as a religious hermit
while living there he claimed friendly
yetis would bring him food and water
allowing him a life of quiet meditation
when one of the yetis died he kept the
scalp as a holy relic in the temple he
built in 1667 this real-life relic
became a part of blessing rituals for
the temple monks later a Yeti hand was
added to the collection another tribute
to the creatures that made the temple
possible
the temple monks refused to allow anyone
to remove the relics for hundreds of
years but in 1959 explorer Peter Byrne
stole a few finger bones from the hand
substituting them with human ones
so Yeti legends and stories were
culturally important long before the
Western world was even aware of their
existence in reality the Yeti entered
into Western thought as a footnote
literally a footnote in a book in 1832
British naturalist Brian H Hodgson
writing about mammals in Nepal noted
that no monkeys could be found in the
northern and central regions but a
footnote mentioned that during one
expedition frightened local shooters
fled what they believed to be a wild man
he was told the creature moved upright
was covered with long dark hair and had
no tail still no monkeys but the tale of
a curious humanoid gave Hodgson pause in
1889 the first mention of Yeti
footprints appeared in among the
Himalayas by British explorer Lawrence a
Weddell he writes that according to
Tibetans the large tracks were made by
what they identified as hairy wild men
who are believed to live amongst the
eternal snows at the turn of the 20th
century the first exploration and
hunting parties descended on the
Himalayas in search of the mysterious
hairy wild man but it wasn't until
Lieutenant Colonel Charles Howard buries
1921 Mount Everest exploration that the
press started to pay attention Howard
Barry and five others saw tracks in the
snow that they could not identify local
laborers accompanying them identified
the tracks as belonging to the wild man
of the snows Howard burry believed the
prints in the snow were from a grey wolf
the one he and his team were interviewed
by journalist Henry Newman the reporter
found no excitement in that explanation
and instead focused on the Tibetan
boogie man with his backward-facing feet
and long matted hair he mistranslated
metal on me which roughly means man
bears snowman as filthy snow man which
he decided sounded better as abominable
snow
something about the name captured the
public's imagination and interest in the
creatures snowballs but expeditions to
search for the Eddy became difficult
because of political and religious
tensions after China invaded Tibet
leading to thousands of deaths until in
1951 an agreement was made affirming
China's sovereignty over Tibet but
allowing their political system to
remain unchanged and religious freedom
to stay protected including the belief
in the meta with a more stable political
climate explorers once again poured into
hunt for the monster most notable was
the 1951 Mount Everest reconnaissance
expedition led by Eric Shipton
which produced the single most famous
piece of Yeti evidence a photograph of a
footprint dubbed the Shipton print the
widely published photo shows a huge
human-like footprint in the snow
reportedly discovered on Mount Everest
at 18,000 feet it was printed everywhere
newspapers science journals and popular
magazines around the world plastered it
across their pages in 1952 a year after
Shipton's famous photograph a swiss
exploration team found possible Yeti
tracks at 16,000 feet a porter even
claimed to be attacked by a Yeti
but the rest of the team didn't
corroborate his story
the monster searched crazed reached such
a level that the Nepalese government
seen an opportunity to exploit the Yeti
began offering special Yeti hunting
licenses in 1954 the popular British
newspaper The Daily Mail funded a
Himalayan Yeti finding expedition Texas
oil man and monster hunter Tom slick
also through his cowboy hat into the
ring
his bio included hunts for Bigfoot and
the Loch Ness monster in the 1950s he
dedicated three expeditions to the Yeti
and Life magazine offered him $25,000
for the rights to any photos he took of
the creature after 1959 tensions in the
area came to a head again and it's a
Benton uprising led to a Chinese
down on Yeti expeditions for fear of
espionage for a decade it was difficult
to travel into the country to look for
the Yeti the two expeditions managed to
wiggle through the cracks between 1960
and 1961 Edmund Hillary and Marlon
Perkins led expeditions with a team of
scientists who examined the infamous
Yeti relic hand and ID'd it as coming
from a modern human although at the time
they didn't know Bern had swapped out
the finger bones shockingly
the monks the temple also allowed them
to take the famous Yeti scalp but only
if one of their elders could accompany
it using the opportunity to raise money
to build schools in Nepal in 1960
separate examinations of the scalp in
London Chicago and Paris found that it
was a fake relic made from Cerro flesh
the discovery appeared to dampen the
spirits of Yeti hunters and expeditions
began to wane none of the expeditions
were able to bring back conclusive
evidence of a Yeti enter Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer
the 1964 Christmas television special
whose fluffy white arguably adorable
Yeti reignited the popularity the famed
white furry character with blue hands
and feet at first seems scary until it's
revealed that it's only suffering from a
toothache the character Bumble is
explicitly called an abominable snow
monster it's my opinion this is the
thing that created the white haired snow
monster Westerners identify as a Yeti
the one most often seen in pop culture
today in the 70s the Chinese government
sent more than a hundred people to
investigate the Yeti after they found
nothing they even allowed Western
expeditions into Tibet again but those
didn't reveal anything either in the
same decade the famous shift in
photograph became widely viewed as a
fake one team member of the 1951
expedition even told a journalist that
it was very possible the photo was a
hoax
given that shiftin definitely liked to
take the mickey out of people and would
think that was quite a good joke but
some of the expeditions over the years
did return with more than photos newly
discovered fragments of bone skin teeth
and fecal matter were all brought back
and investigated but nothing concludes
developed it seems that every time some
new scientific insight attempts to
answer is the Yeti real the world pays
attention take the bouton discovery for
example and 2001 a British zoologist
collected a few strands of hair from a
hollow cedar tree in Bhutan under DNA
analysis the hair could not be
identified as coming from any animal
known to science with this conclusive
proof that some yet unidentified
creature lived in the Himalayas not
exactly in 2014
Yeti made the news again when a study
showed that the hair actually came from
an extinct Paleolithic polar bear in
2017 a team of scientists analyzed
another 24 supposed Yeti specimens taken
from the Himalayas and Tibetan Plateau
including bone tooth skin hair and fecal
samples all but one of the samples which
came from a dog were from bears
including Himalayan bears who occupy the
northwestern plateau Himalayan Bears
have paler reddish-brown fur which seems
awfully like the hair in the
descriptions of the original Tibetan
yetis interestingly the scientists
discovered that the Himalayan brown bear
came from a unique evolutionary lineage
that diverged from all other brown bears
around 650,000 years ago so in their
report the scientists say that the
study's findings strongly suggest that
yetis are based on local brown and black
bears I happen to agree bears also play
a really important role in Tibetan
mythology and lore there's belief in a
half human and half brown bear creature
called the me dread an upper Tibet among
the Chinese Najee people apes marmots
brown bears and Mead red are the four
brothers who are like humans but are not
human they were believed to have the
same ancestry because they are all
capable of standing on their back legs
folklore tells of brown bears abducting
women and producing children with them
and of brown bears leaving human
footprints Tibetan folklore religion
scientific discoveries there's actually
a lot going on with this monster it's
kind of amazing
both the snarling bloodthirsty dad
we see in some depictions
and the kinder helpful versions we see
in others have some basis in Himalayan
folklore but ultimately they only touch
the surface the more dangerous
representations promote a healthy sense
of weariness around bears or service
warnings of the very real dangers of the
snow and high altitude and the kinder
helpful versions of the Yeti speak to
the Buddhist belief that all living
things have a purpose and a place in the
world around 65 thousand years ago
sixty-five hundred thousand years ago
right holy moly
sixty-five hundred thousand six six
hundred and fifty thousand